نعم ليلى كما كنا نشاهد في هذه التغطيه
نحن في اليوم ال اوش بعد المئه لهذه الحرب
واللافت ايضا استهداف تل ابيب لنشاهد هذه
المسافه هنا من اقصى شمال قطاع غزه
المسافه باتجاه تل ابيب تصل حوالي 58 ك
الى نحو 60 اذا ما اخذنا الوسط الى تل
ابيب هنا نتحدث عن حوالي 22 را من خان
يونس وجنوب خان يونس نحن نتحدث تقريبا
حوالي 100 ك اي ان مدى الصواريخ هو في
المدى ما هو المتوسط او بعد المتوسط
بمقارنه بمثل هذه الحالات عاده
الاستهدافات كانت تكون في غلاف غ غزه هذا
هو ال الامر اللافت الاول نتحدث عن مدى من
60 الى 100 م بالنسبه للصواريخ التي
استخدمت ايضا نلاحظ هذا اللون الاصفر هنا
هذا اللون الاصفر في كامل قطاع غزه هو
للمناورات الاسرائيليه البريه اي انها
كانت تدخل في هذه المناطق من الشرق باتجاه
الغرب ودخلت في شمال القطاع وسط القطاع
وجنوب القطاع الهدف احد الاهداف الرئيسيه
للعمليات البريه هي ايجاد الانفاق مناطق
الانفاق الهجوميه التي تستخدم لاطلاق
الصواريخ
باتجاه غلاف غزه باتجاه تلبي باتجاه
الشمال وباتجاه الجنوب فبالتالي وجود مثل
هذه اطلاق هذا الاطلاق وباتجاه تلبيب وهذه
المسافات الكبيره سيثير التساؤلات
عن اهداف العمليه الاسرائيليه هل تستطيع
تحقيق اهدافها على تستطيع تحقيق اهدافها
في العمليات التكتيكيه هنا في القضاء على
الانفاق الهجوميه التي تستطيع الاستهداف
خاصه مع وجود هذا اللون الاصفر هنا في
كافه مناطق القطاع في الشمال في الوسط
اضافه الى الجنوب والتوغل العسكريه في غرب
خان يونس وجنوب خان يونس حيث مركز ثقل
العمليات هذه هي ابرز الامور التي لدينا
لينا في الخريطه التفاعليه ونعود للتحليل
معكما واللواء فايز